BURKE HOLLAND: All right.
Hey everybody.
Welcome back.
And we're joined by Joanna,
who's the Design
Lead on VS Code.
How many designers
are there on VS Code?
JOANNA OIKAWA: There are four.
BURKE HOLLAND: Four designers.
JOANNA OIKAWA: Yes.
A small but mighty Design
and UX Engineering Team.
BURKE HOLLAND: Yes.
So interesting back story here.
For those of you who are
here, you get to hear this.
There is a UX channel in
the chat, and it's one
of my favorites, because
you'll see tons of stuff there
that never sees the light of
day, but all the prototypes,
you're like, I've been thinking,
what if chat looked like this?
And you're like, that's amazing.
It's one of my favorite
places to hang out
and just watch the
tower building.
Very cool.
JOANNA OIKAWA: Yeah.
It's great because a lot of
the engineers also own UX.
And so we're able to
have a small team
and work really quickly,
because everybody is thinking
and sharing and
owning UX together.
BURKE HOLLAND: Yeah,
it's very cool.
I wish I was a designer.
JOANNA OIKAWA: You could.
BURKE HOLLAND: If you
could have one ability
that you don't have,
what would it be?
JOANNA OIKAWA: Me?
BURKE HOLLAND: Yeah.
JOANNA OIKAWA: Oh, my gosh.
Probably print making,
like physical posters
and graphic design, a
little bit more of that.
BURKE HOLLAND: It
wouldn't be singing,
Celine Dion or something?
You could have picked anything.
JOANNA OIKAWA: Oh, I could
have picked anything,
and I picked something
very close to my mom.
BURKE HOLLAND: You're
living your best life.
Okay. So almost shipped designs.
Are there a couple of
examples that we can see?
JOANNA OIKAWA: Sure.
Yeah. I mean, I have kind of a
walkthrough of what our journey
to the agents window looks.
And that includes a lot
of things that are close
but not quite what we ended
up shipping, and some things
that we're still thinking about.
So I have, here in Figma, you
can see back in December,
we were starting to think about
what the evolution of that
"Agents" panel that we
launched last fall was going
to look like.
How can we make it easier
to switch and check
on your agents while
you're focused in VS Code?
And so we start to play with
this menu that's attached
to the central
search bar as a way
to quickly find those things.
And you can see in the product
today, we have a similar menu,
but we grew and learned
more about the feedback.
And so we started to think more
about what a full-screen
experience would look like,
still within the concept
of the same editor window,
but we started with
the welcome page.
And we ended up shipping
something close to this,
but one of the key
differences was what kind
of information we
wanted to show here.
And so this took a lot of
feedback, user research,
to learn about what data
across what workspaces do
you want to see things.
And we really learned that a lot
of folks wanted to see sessions
across different projects.
BURKE HOLLAND: How do
you make that decision?
Is it just looking at telemetry?
I mean, this seems like
this stuff is hard.
It's extremely hard.
And when you see products that
are really well designed,
they're just easy to use, that
is extremely difficult to do.
So I'm very curious about, like,
how do you figure out which one
of these designs is the
right one to go with?
JOANNA OIKAWA: It's a challenge
because we're working
in an existing product
with existing patterns
and preferences and then trying
to support new ways
of working entirely.
BURKE HOLLAND: Yeah.
Modalities that we don't really
know what they look like.
JOANNA OIKAWA: And so we're
learning about them on our team.
And our customers, our users
are learning about them.
And it's kind of building
the boat while it's running
type thing.
BURKE HOLLAND: Yeah,
we're changing the wheels
on the bus while it's -- so who
makes the final call on that?
Is that you?
Are you the one who says
ship it or don't ship it?
JOANNA OIKAWA: We're always
kind of improving on it,
so there's not
usually a final call.
We'll put it into
insiders first.
We'll experiment.
BURKE HOLLAND: Oh, that's right.
Test rollout.
JOANNA OIKAWA:
We'll run research.
We'll get feedback.
And then we're just kind of
continuously touching a lot
of these problem spaces
as we learn more,
as our users learn more.
No one really calls
it final on the team.
We just kind of keep going
until we're happy with it.
BURKE HOLLAND: Okay.
And y'all have something
called UI Power Hour.
UI Power Hour.
Is that a thing?
JOANNA OIKAWA: I don't know.
BURKE HOLLAND: It says
what it is, how it works,
and why it matters
at this velocity.
JOANNA OIKAWA: I have no idea.
BURKE HOLLAND: The AI
has hallucinated facts.
AI designers shipping their
own fixes, oh, with Figma MCP.
Nice.
JOANNA OIKAWA: Yeah, absolutely.
We have taken advantage of the
capability to take designs
from Figma, just like
this, and move them
into code more quickly and,
more importantly, take code
and update our Figma components,
so that you can work
in either tool, whatever
is easiest for you.
And all of our designers
ship code as well.
And so we --
BURKE HOLLAND: Oh, really?
Are you submitting PRs?
JOANNA OIKAWA: Yes.
BURKE HOLLAND: Now is that a
change from 12 months ago,
or has it always been that way?
JOANNA OIKAWA: A lot
of former designers,
like David Dossett, have
been very integrated
in the code base as well.
But it's kind of a
new thing for us.
So we're finding that balance
of when to submit PRs,
when to just create prototypes,
when to just work in Figma,
what's most efficient.
We have a lot of web-based
prototypes as well that we use.
This is from last December as
well when we were starting
to talk about our new
themes and color refreshes
and what were some of
the experimental styles
that we wanted to play with.
And so prototyping these to make
them interactive was excellent.
And we didn't end up
shipping this exact code,
but it gave us
something to share
with the team, gather feedback.
And you can see some of the
options that we had here,
like the shadow on the panels,
the lighter panels than the rest
of the background,
these are things
that we ended up changing.
BURKE HOLLAND: The VS Code icon
in the top right
corner was flashing.
I like that.
JOANNA OIKAWA: Yeah.
The evolution of this
is the "Update" button
that lives up there now.
But we got feedback that the
flashing button was a little
too much.
BURKE HOLLAND: A
little too annoying?
JOANNA OIKAWA: Yeah.
So maybe we'll just
add it for you.
BURKE HOLLAND: I really like it.
Okay. So what I'm hearing,
Joanna, because I heard this
from Courtney as well, is
that everybody is now --
would it be accurate to say
that everyone is a developer?
In other words, PMs
are submitting PRs.
Designers are submitting PRs.
So that, to me, seems
to be a huge change.
The job has really expanded
beyond just design.
JOANNA OIKAWA: Everyone
is a developer,
and everyone is a
designer as well.
Like I said, a lot
of our engineers --
BURKE HOLLAND: That's very true.
JOANNA OIKAWA: -- they're able
to come up with new ideas
and get farther in the UX
process than they would have
in the past because they
have more design guidelines
that are available, and the code
can look at what's happened
in the past, and they can bring
a prototype to us for feedback.
BURKE HOLLAND: Yeah,
that's very true.
JOANNA OIKAWA: And so
we get to share a lot
of responsibilities
because of these tools.
BURKE HOLLAND: It moves
in both directions.
I'm curious, do y'all think
that maybe in the future,
the job is you do everything?
Do you know what I mean?
You're a designer and
a PM and an engineer.
Everyone literally
does everything.
We don't have siloed
disciplines anymore.
Or no?
JOANNA OIKAWA: The
way I think about it
and the way our team thinks
about it is depth
versus breadth.
And so my depth will
probably always be
in user experience
and visual design.
And that's where my deep
expertise comes in.
But with AI, you can have more
breadth than in the past.
So, for instance, writing
a Kusto query used
to take me forever, and
it was really cumbersome
and difficult to do.
But now I can look up
data on our telemetry
and make decisions off
of that much easier.
So I can put on that
analyst hat, PM hat,
even though I don't have
that extreme depth.
BURKE HOLLAND: So for
those folks who don't work
in Microsoft, Kusto is, well,
Kuso is a public
thing, too, I think.
But Kusto is a language for
querying telemetry and data.
And Microsoft is
very data driven.
Right? It doesn't just
make decisions on the fly.
Everything has to
be backed by data.
So we used to have people
whose sole job was
to write Kusto queries
and then make dashboards
and present that data.
That was Devon.
That's what he did.
And if you needed data,
you'd have to go to Devon,
because he's the
only one who knew.
But I guess now just
anyone could do it.
JOANNA OIKAWA: We're able
to get farther on our own.
BURKE HOLLAND: Holy crap.
This place is coming apart.
As far as design, though,
goes with agents,
one of the things
I've noticed is
that we talk about AI psychosis.
And one of the ways that it
manifests is that now I think
that I'm a good designer.
And so the AI makes the design.
I'm like, I really like that.
And other people will
show me their thing.
They're like, I built this
with Opus or whatever,
and they're super proud of
it, and it's just purple
and gradients all
over the place.
I'm like, that is a monstrosity.
So it does seem like, yes, you
can do, but also there needs
to be someone in the
room who's like,
we're not going to do that.
Close.
JOANNA OIKAWA: That's
where the depth
and the taste comes in,
having folks, and, similarly,
having engineers who can
tell me that's not possible,
or that's not smart, or it's
going to slow down the app,
when I have this fun idea.
Having these complementary
depths really helps find the
right balance for the product.
BURKE HOLLAND: So I know
we're kind of off the rails
of design, but I'm interested
in this, because if you're old
like me, I've been
around for so long
that I've just seen
everything, right?
So it's like taste and
experience is more of just,
like, I've just done every
stupid thing you can do.
And so I know how it all ends.
I've burned myself
every possible way.
I'm just covered in blisters.
How do we develop the
taste if you don't get
to get burned anymore because
the agent is doing all the work?
I'm worried about how do we
create more of these folks?
JOANNA OIKAWA: That's why
having a validation loop
and making sure what you're
shipping is solving the problem
that you intended, and
you're getting feedback,
and you're kind of
closing the loop
on decisions that you're making.
That's how you'll actually
find out is this little thing
that I vibe coded,
added really quickly,
is it actually
solving the problem,
or does it have a greater sense
of importance and permanence
because it's out
there and available?
So holding ourselves
responsible for making sure
that the things we ship
work and taking things
out when it doesn't work,
because it's so easy
to just add, add, add, add, add.
BURKE HOLLAND: Yeah,
it's fascinating.
It is easy to do.
I almost feel like we're at
the point, especially with AI,
where it's like, I don't
know if y'all have ever --
are there any artists in the
room, people who paint or draw?
If you draw, then you know
that when you're drawing,
there is a point at which
you should stop drawing.
From here on out, you're
just going to make it worse.
And I feel like that's
the same way with AI.
You can build every
possible feature,
but you should really
stop and consider whether
or not you should do that.
JOANNA OIKAWA: And
that's been a big theme
with the Agents Window, because
we want to provide a place
where you can focus
and easily navigate
and complement the craziness
of running multiple
agents in parallel.
And that requires kind
of pulling back things
that historically might have
been an option in VS Code.
And so I'll even show in Figma
here what that started to look
when we realized we needed kind
of a separate window in a space
to look across multiple projects
and have that focused view.
We really questioned every
single element on the screen
of whether it was going to be --
BURKE HOLLAND:
Distracting or necessary.
JOANNA OIKAWA: -- needed.
Does it help me make
decisions in this moment,
or does it add more information
and options and distractions?
And so we played a lot with
what the output looks like,
what the session list
information needs to include,
and then even at this level,
what information do I need
to start my day to
check on things,
to babysit multiple agents at
a time, and how do we balance
that with not making
people feel overwhelmed
and like there's too many
things happening at once
that it's out of their control.
BURKE HOLLAND: Well, I, on
behalf of all developers,
am thankful for designers
who can help us ship
good-looking stuff.
Thank you so much.
A round of applause for Joanna.
JOANNA OIKAWA: Thanks
for having me.
BURKE HOLLAND: You're
my favorite designer.
Don't tell Elijah I said that.
All right.
Thanks so much.
All right, folks,
we'll be right back.
We're going to do Doom next.
I don't know how.
[ Music ]